talk to me when you stream for like 16
hours and don't win that's
oh i did i did exactly that don't worry
my sister and i we were like okay we're
gonna end stream once we won it was like
seven hours later
we did that a few days in a row so
definitely put in more than 16 hours
oh wow oh wow oh wow all right oh
we have kind of the same well we have
e45 knight c3 the vienna game
this is interesting this is cutting edge
theory now you know there's different uh
instances of bishop c4 knight f3 one
it's better to play one move versus the
other
a lot of grandmasters they opt for c6
and knight f6 when you play bishop c4
what is austin going to play here as
long as he doesn't push that pawn i'm
happy
yeah that's a move that well queen g4
here is actually i think one of the
theoretical ones knight f3 though
he seems very well coached in the
opening i mean his first couple moves
are
solid and uh basically the best moves in
the position
and again mountain is doing some weird
stuff guys
yeah he doesn't really follow most
opening principles but he does
that's the thing when he plays he does
so what's going on it's the pressure
which i don't even know how lower would
weight will under pressure ladies and
gentlemen rook g1
what a that is a very subtle move he is
going for the kingside attack g4
um now knight d5 there was very good
attacking the queen instead
yes that was the move that actually
would have put uh
half door in a difficult situation
he's playing on all fronts here guys
he's he's attacking on the queen set and
on the kings i think half thor is just
going to resign he's this is too
overwhelming
i remember go ahead andre oh yeah i was
going to say
austin calculated this out by knowing
that thor moved his queen early he knew
he was going to king side castle so it
was all planned
right king attack yes he had done a
lesson with his coach
on the fact that you can let your
opponent commit their king to a side of
the world exactly
and then play g4 h4 and a4 has a long
a long-term idea of playing rook a3
clearing out the third rank
and getting a rook on to g3 right a
mastermind plan there let me ask the two
of you another question
oh you know that when rook f1
repositioning is
castling except the kings on e1 i was
going to say
you know when beginners start off play
chess they play a4 and rook a3
why do beginners have a tendency to move
their pawns is it that they're afraid to
move their central pawns why is there
this
i think they just like pushing their
pawns in general i remember when i'd
play against when i was a younger kid
everyone would just go
a4 b4 c4 everything so
interesting um my my scholastic students
from my program were
all well-equipped and you know
cutting-edge night or theory uh poison
pawn variation
uh sometimes taiman of you know o'kelly
to mix it up but
uh other times you have berlin why
didn't they play the semester
though terrible teacher i mean any
self-respecting coach especially from
new york should teach their students to
sveshnikov
i know but we were getting a lot of
rossolimo you know so we wanted to avoid
okay wait guys i have a serious question
do you think austin knows how to castle
he just said in the chat he was trying
to castle i don't think he does
no that's why he probably thought like
rook g1 would somehow switch spots with
his king
and then he gave it a second try with
rook f1
just that's like me trying to tie a tie
or something you just like
you know throw it around just hope it
materializes yeah it actually never does
yes i haven't had to tie it in a while
they're all just tied in my like in
in the closet already i just put them on
because otherwise it's just like uh
okay let's try that again um
[Music]
yeah so he's only got one way to defend
this queen well a few but yes the block
is essentially the way see if he'll find
it
i have a bad feeling he might take that
but sure no he does
okay good move i like it
h5 keeping it keeping the pin i'd say
maybe it could manual castle but the
problem is the bishop on c5 he's never
going to get that diagonal
[Music]
for white knight f5 here attacking the
queen would be a very sensible move but
austin's got to find a way to
disentangle his pieces here he's really
tangled up
disentangle you got puns and vocabulary
you learned that on bigwords.com as well
i did bigwords.com big sponsor of chess
indeed indeed all right austin's
defending his night he's being a little
bit cautious here
um decent instincts
g3 and f3 is very interesting because
because he also has knight f5
which is a very legitimate idea
definitely
i don't know if you will see knight f5
though
yeah and after thinking about what to do
he can take the pawn on e4 he can keep
developing
very complicated position
but again if he did like two
hours of just training he'd be
he'd be super his openings wouldn't be
bad and a lot of it is confidence a lot
of it is you you
arrive at the board and you're like i'm
gonna lose i have no idea what i'm just
gonna play moves
whereas chess is so much about
confidence
so much about confidence like you have
to believe in the fact that you're gonna
win the game or the match
before you get there and so he just
needs a little bit of that he'll be fine
hide a2 you think he's going to go b4
next
maybe he broke b1 that'd be a good plan
i think maybe he thought
he saw that oh 92 would be blocking his
queen and taking space from his king
maybe he has a good thought process here
let's go let's go watch some half door
asmr
that's what i want to see right now
sounds great
i would love some have to raise some
more
breathing heavily
oh wow
this is quality content i'm very it's
too intense why
i feel like he's breathing abnormally
fast
maybe not maybe not this is
this is good why is he is huffing and
puffing
i think he's just saying something i
don't think he's saying anything if he's
saying something i'm
terrified now right that fire will come
out oh
the breathing intensifies his nose i
think he's eating his microphone
his nose is literally chilling on the
mic
protein pancakes weren't good enough he
needs to eat the whole mic
yeah next thing we're just gonna gobble
up the entire mic
also went back to rook g1 that's a
pretty
you know what i like he hasn't blundered
everything is solid that's true
that's a great point and rook g1 was a
pretty great move maybe he actually is
going for the king attack
or he's just making his king
yeah it's not easy to make a movie for
black like i mean there's many
solid moves okay and mp6 is decent
all right let's let's go back to the big
board we can leave
we can leave the audio on for after
right he's not gonna say anything he'll
just be breathing the entire time no we
don't have to do that that's that's
gonna be chaos
uh knight b6 that attacks the a4 pawn
do you guys think austin will go for the
king side attack
or is he gonna get distracted by thor's
last move on the queen side
i mean i think he's going to go maybe a5
or like b3
a5 would be a decent move except it
wouldn't c4
but it's a good try b4 maybe
it's 13 moves in and the position is in
the balance the eval bar
i know is a little bit uh in mountains
favor
that's just because he's breathing very
hard and scaring it but normally it
would be
closer to about equal well i think he's
going to eat the eval varsity and it
might disappear from our board
i've heard it's high in protein
this is definitely one of austin's best
games even though he played the opening
very strange and wasted a lot of time
with his rook
his position is not too bad so he's gone
c3 actually defending the pawn on a4
very nice oh actually no d takes c3
exposes the rook on g1
yeah that is that's tough to see uh
afterward takes but does he see bishop g
he dies austin was calculating he was
seeing that queen
defense but he missed that bishop wow
look at the speed with which thor took
that he those protein pancakes were
definitely not enough
yeah he's looking for more that's the
second time
that's actually this if you guys
remember in the first game bishop c4
took g8
and we got bishop c5 austin is repeating
the same mistake
so that is just something you know a
long-range bishop attack
he took it instantly he saw it all that
comes from his experience
um i also just realized that
i didn't have to remute it this entire
time on my computer
he just said a word he had not spoken in
five minutes
he said all right
is he slapping himself i think he's uh
finally
he was very serious deep breathing but
now he's cooled down a little bit
he's talking relaxed he just leaned back
because he won that rook you can tell
he's feeling feeling a little bit better
oh and oh f4 is somewhat unfortunate
move
and there goes the queen i've told you
he was saying
he's actually singing he not yet he
hasn't taken it just yet but it's the
same distance
right there's three squares in between
the queen and the rand
yeah he he does smarter
so i did say that austin had not
blundered and that's just the difficulty
of a closed position
your all your pieces are locked together
and the second you create an opening
bishop long range piece just come
straight down pawn moves up
door opens for the other bishop and uh
looks like it's going to be 2-0 indeed
he takes f4 here would be sensible
which he does wow excellent technique
here displayed by half thor
this is this is difficult
that all you can eat buffet you
mentioned the plates are starting to get
stocked up
94 yeah another good move yeah i mean
this was a pretty tough matchup for
austin
yeah so
i know austin's got one more match up
wait is that a matchup against wagamama
oh no um let's see
i really hope not it is it is oh
austin a couple hours of coaching
oh man but wagon mom is even stronger
than
thor on the board of course um
maybe i mean it's the you know physical
strength is debatable the chess board
what what if we do like a crowd effort
we do like
chat votes when austin plays against
no it's like so like austin doesn't play
his game
pretty much then listen austin
is in in this bracket like in this group
group d i don't know if we have like the
full standings but in in group d we
we've got wagga momma who is
in my opinion the strongest player in
the event uh not a lot of people are
talking about it because hafu has been
doing a lot of lessons a lot of training
but
uh wow this is about to be checked made
in in two weeks
one flawless technique by malcolm
just do a cross what was that he looks
very puzzled oh
okay we're deciding to just uh you know
chill a little bit take a couple more
pawns
yeah yeah like austin and connor will
get another chance in the consolation
bracket
so that is true that's probably he's
praying
but i don't even know what he's praying
for here no no no
he's hovering where the c3 square no way
okay come on no thor won't beat his
gambit here
he's doing that thing where he's
touching all his pieces again sorry
go ahead i was just gonna say
he likes to taste them all andrea and
alexandra have to
have you know do an intervention with
with austin and just be like listen
we got a chance at redemption in the
consolation bracket
let's go it's going to be the biggest
redemption arc
of 2020 i agree we'll have to convince
austin to do some lessons because i know
my sister tried one and they just got
distracted and like talked about
piloting for about a few hours
but at least she taught him the pieces
that lesson so
what wait about uh flight simulator yeah
cause austin
i think he has some piloting experience
like real life really simulator wow yeah
it's his favorite hobby and he actually
i did the first
um i think it was a flight simulator
stream
but that's exciting for him because he's
finally doing use his first time doing
solo content
that is very cool there's a lot of mates
okay he just goes for the latter
yeah that actually is very cool i mean
piloting is awesome that night knight d1
there is still queen b2
by the way you'd like a fancy checkmate
well uh congratulations
to the mountain uh i think we are going
to do
our usual break after the games are over
see whether both players or one of them
will be joining us to talk with us
about the games life piloting and
whatnot
don't go anywhere short break we'll be
right back with interviews
what's that in pounds yeah pounds well
is 400 pounds so it's a little bit less
than
400. so as you guys can see he had a
huge size advantage
in this match i mean it just wasn't even
fair from the beginning really um
yeah so you know it's okay austin you
have the
the hair advantage because i know you're
always worried about your hair
but it was on point today thank you so
it must have made you feel good
thank you at least something was on
point uh today
uh you know we're gonna have to off the
go it wasn't my best performance i'm
gonna have to go look at the tape
and uh you know see what went wrong uh
you know as far as i'm aware about
everything went wrong
um you know stupid effing mistakes
actually your first game was going
pretty well
like we thought you prepared opening
there did you do any preparation oh you
did
i did i prepared an opening but i i i
don't know what happened i didn't
prepare the finish
what happened i
am very much uh team austin i i've been
i've been saying if you get
don't say that levy why would you say
that he can get away with that because
i'm not gonna win so it's
he just get away with it he can get away
with that that's that's something in
in every other component you know but
anyway go on i was just saying like
obviously i've played i've played uh i
coached after a couple times
uh he's done a lot of lessons with
everybody and also he's played chess
in the past so i'm just saying if you
get like
like two good hours maybe a third if
you're up for
it uh with the botel sisters like you'll
be
you'll be a beast i mean you'll be like
top two top three in the consolation
bracket
yeah i i think uh yeah i i i did i
it was very valuable the 30 minutes that
i spent with uh
alexandra was very valuable i learned
what the pieces were
um and where they moved uh and then my
uh
knowledge sort of stopped and i forgot
how to castle so
um awesome wasn't that less than like
three hours
it was a three hour lesson yes um i i it
just felt like 30 minutes it just blew
by
well i think the chess only was 30
minutes and then you guys just got a
little bit distracted
yeah we were talking about work on that
well and also i want to i want to
correct the record here i get a lot of
flack for my 285 score but i want to
make it known
that that score was drawn down because i
had to play
alexandra for the tied laundry trials
repeatedly
okay so that's why the score is as low
as it was okay well you know
you know uh when we do speed runs we can
ask for a reset
rating so yeah you just you know you see
what they say i mean worse comes to
worse they say no but
um
uh congratulations uh i
was going to ask you how come you play a
little bit differently in the opening
during pogchamps than you usually do
because you play kind of
timid you some setups aren't optimal
what's what's going on
i i feel like i i do uh what i usually
do i try
to uh castle quickly i try to push my
pawn up where my king is it's called the
italian moor something i can remember
the name of
it yeah yeah and
yeah i feel like i've been doing that in
the past um
yeah he was a dirty player
unbelievable dirty
dirty do we want to go over the the
first game where
thor pushed f3 and austin had that
brilliant night move with his queen
pledge yes
gentlemen uh you might see it on the
live board i don't know if you have it
open
uh but move six knight h5
from austin was a brilliancy
uh this was a very deep move
yes i really i really dug deep for that
move you know
and uh really came with a lot of
forethought and uh foresight
he just forgot to follow up right yeah
he you know he faked he faked the shot
but then he didn't
he didn't yeah did not follow through
it was actually a very nice idea um
but so you know i've talked to both of
you
uh about separately at least about
positioning in terms of the brackets
your next matchup
can start with uh half tour you are
going up i think against
connor sorry i'm just
laughing at the idea often you're going
up against the computer
austin you're not the only one you're
going we can actually not
find a opponent as bad to put you up
against
um anyway go on sorry
no no i was just gonna say uh after as
of now
what is your goal in the uh in the event
i mean i i think we'll see you in
championship bracket
you know you're gonna win the entire
thing do you want to call out anybody
well firstly you know it's just an honor
to
you know be a part of this event um
exactly i'm just here to have fun and do
my best
you know obviously i want to win each
and every game
i am going to do my best in each and
every game uh
i know there's a lot of talented people
that are playing
um so if i want to be able to win
i have to keep practicing keep
getting classes with these amazing
people that have been so
helpful um and you just just keep
grinding basically because like i feel
there's a lot to
improve uh i'm i'm still
every single day making blunders you
know um
making mistakes uh so there's a lot to
improve and
and i wanna improve and i wanna i want
to get better and and hopefully you know
if i'm able to improve
um enough i'll i'll take it all all the
way
that was so wholesome yeah that was that
was great oh my god i was like trying to
divvy up how much time i was about to
give austin for a final word
um well austin you've got the floor for
like 15 seconds before we put up the
next match-up card what do you got to
say to your next opponent
wagamama the perennial all i can say is
best of luck to you i'm going to put in
a hard training session thor
it's an absolute pleasure to lose to you
and best of luck for the rest of the
competition
thank you guys for being two are two
wholesome thank you we'll hit the gym
sometime thor
absolutely any time okay there you go